heute geht es nur um albert einstein und
seine spezielle relativitätstheorie um
diesen netten herrn hier dieser sehr
langen zunge und ich hatte das letzte
mal erzählt es gibt das annus mirabilis
das wunder ja das ist es ja 1905 gab es
auch vor 13 jahren im jahr 2005 eine
große feier anlässlich des erscheinens
dieses aufsatzes elektro dynamik
bewegter körper es hat aber auch noch
andere veröffentlichung von einstein in
diesem jahr gegeben glaubt noch drei
weitere glaubt ihren ganz wichtige und
es meinten mal ein physiker albert
einstein hätte für jedes die jeden
dieser aufsätze in diesem jahr einen
nobelpreis für sich verdient er hat ihn
aber auch gar nicht dafür bekommen für
diesen aufsatz hat noch etwas anderes
bekommen ich glaube irgendwie molekül
bewegung oder ist so was also gar nicht
für diesen aufsatz in diesem aufsatz von
dem wir heute auch ein stück lesen
werden hat albert einstein nichts
geringeres als die spezielle
relativitätstheorie in ihren grundzügen
entwickelt aber davor
bevor wir jetzt hier einfach so drauflos
philosophieren muss ich noch mal die
kritische rückfragen an uns als
philosophin und philosophen stellen
inwiefern können wir sie und ich als
philosophin und philosophen überhaupt
sinnvoll
über die ergebnisse der
relativitätstheorie diskutieren
vielleicht können wir noch mal ganz kurz
ein bisschen meinungen sammeln
wie gesagt stellen sie sich vor es gibt
also eine kritische physikerin die ihrem
semester ist so weit ist wie sie so alt
ist wie sie an kritischen physiker der
das nicht so toll findet oder die das
nicht so toll findet dass wir hier
einfach so ohne eine physikalische oder
mathematische ausbildung unter umständen
genossen zu haben jetzt sie einfach uns
anmaßen über die ergebnisse der
speziellen relativitätstheorie zu
philosophieren
jetzt überlegen sie mal die physikerin
dieser physiker sagt was ihr macht euch
an darüber zu reden ja ihr könnt doch
darüber gar nicht kompetent reden
das denke ich zumindest immer wenn ich
mir darüber gedanken machen wie es mit
dem physik leistungskurs aber das ist
nicht hinreichend dafür was können sie
jetzt zu einem kritischen physiker einer
kritischen physikerin antworten ohne den
eindruck zu erwecken bei jemand dabei
ihr dass sie sich etwas anmaßen dass sie
hier über etwas reden worüber sie
eigentlich gar nicht reden dürften weil
sie da gar keine ausbildung drin
genossen haben was könnten sie denn zu
einer kritischen physikerin einen
kritischen physiker antworten
ich habe in der zusammenfassung schon
ein bisschen was geschrieben auf basis
unserer diskussion wir hatten ja jetzt
mal kurz wird diskutiert aber ich finde
die frage müssen wir trotzdem noch
einmal erklären uns überhaupt bewusst
darüber zu werden wie wir jetzt darüber
sprechen sollen wie wir diese ergebnisse
bewerten soll darüber gibt was das
könnten sie jetzt sagen wenn die
physikerin das jetzt mal sehr freundlich
sagt ich habe da so meine bedenken dass
ihr da sie da überhaupt darüber reden
können das ist nicht fair bereich
befasst bild lieber mit kant oder mit
ich weiß nicht was da ist es aber lasst
doch die spezielle und schon ganz die
allgemeine relativitätstheorie den
physikern ja
die jungen gesagt sind ihre fähigkeit so
besteht das gesagte leben in entenhausen
der taschenlampe sollten wir vielleicht
können wir das versuchen wir versuchen
bestimmte sachen gut also dass wir
solche fragen stellen die sich die
physikerin oder die biologin oder der
biologe gar nicht stellen oder auch die
sie gar nicht reflektieren die gar nicht
in ihren fokus liegt dass die
philosophen eine stufe höher noch mal
sitzen noch einmal grundlegende frage so
methodologische warum wird das überhaupt
so gemacht und das nicht gut
genau da nicht soviel alter bestimmte
größen werden einfach eingeführt und der
physik als er verständlich als nicht
mehr weiter hinterfragbar erinnern sie
sich an guten noten sagt die absolute
zeit setze ich voraus
sie fließt gleichmäßig und mit der
operiere ich weiter und dahin angesichts
dieser rahmenbedingungen wird
angerechnet
aber diese großen rahmenbedingungen die
werden selbst nicht mehr in frage
gestellt und da könnte dann die
philosophie ansetzen und fragen ja muss
es denn so sein dass die zeit
gleichmäßig fließt könnte es nicht auch
anders sein
also habe außerhalb diesen
rahmenbedingungen zu denken
wenn wir das ist jetzt hier so eine
rahmenbedingungen da haben wir jetzt
hier objekte oder irgendetwas anderes
dann würde die physik hier sich damit
beschäftigt mit diesen sachen hier
sie wird diesen rahmen voraussetzen oder
den könnte sie gar nicht entitäten das
was annehmen aber sie stellt diesen
rahmen selbst nicht in frage
sie müssen voraussetzen und hier könnte
dann die philosophie ansätzen zu haben
muss es denn so sein dass die zeit
überall gleichmäßig verrinnt oder könnte
sie nicht mehr schneller verringern
vor allem das natürlich könnte man sich
genau dasselbe auch mit dem raum fragen
ist der raum überall gleich ausgedehnt
oder gibts nicht so was wie längen
kontraktion dass also die länge eines
gegenstandes von der geschwindigkeit ab
hängt mit der er bewegt wird oder man
könnte noch weiter fragen ist es
wirklich so dass sich die
geschwindigkeit oder die bewegung immer
weiter erhöhen lässt dass es immer
schneller wird ein gegenstand im raum
hauptzeit immer schneller wird und bis
ins unendliche
oder könnte es nicht so die absolute
geschwindigkeit geben
ja
ja ja als jedenfalls hat es die hat die
philosophie ist mit grundbegriffen zu
tun und raum und zeit und sowas ist
sicherlich ein grund begriff haben sie
noch weitere also mit der anschauen was
wissenschaftliche ergebnisse würden wir
das verlieren sagt investor
das ist optimistisch gedacht das ist
natürlich sehr optimistisch gedacht aber
ich stimme ihm jedenfalls auch zu dass
wir so denken sollten
ob so gemacht wird ist dann immer eine
andere frage faktisch gut es geht in die
richtung des kommilitonen der sagte die
physik spricht nur quantitativ von raum
und zeit also von soma thematisiert bar
und könnte man nicht auch mal qualitativ
von raum und zeit sprechen
das führt zum beispiel dazu aus ein
anderer punkt jedenfalls dass wir dann
von zeit reden und des gegenwärtigen
zukünftigen vergangen dass man
vielleicht auch sagt wir müssen diese
dimensionen mit einbeziehen und sinnvoll
über zeit reden zu können die physik
abstrahierter von ich hab noch weiteren
punkt da habe ich noch jemand vergessen
hier der sich gemeldet hat das hatte ich
auch letztes mal gesagt die physik fragt
nach ergebnissen die physik muss ihre
theorien ihre hypothesen ich sage sich
verifizieren aber sie muss sie
überprüfen können also muss genau
genommen wahrscheinlich falsifizieren
also wir machen generelle aussagen wir
formulierende thesen der theorie und
dann schauen wir wie weit die trägt die
theorie hat nur soweit geltung
gültigkeit wie sie empirisch nicht
widerlegt werden kann und solange sie
noch nicht widerlegt werden kann
so lange müssen wir hypothetisch davon
ausgehen dass sie war es also wahrheit
hat auch in der physik in der
empirischen naturwissenschaften wenn die
physik sich als empirische wissenschaft
versteht eine naturwissenschaft
immer nur einen hypothetischen charakter
also was wie eine absolute wahrheit die
ohne eigentlich von erfahrung gültig
wäre wird man nur selten in den
naturwissenschaften formulieren deswegen
könnte man sagen in den
naturwissenschaften ist wahrheit immer
der irrtum auf dem neuesten stand
gebracht na also der neueste irrtum ist
dort die wahrheit
bis eben die vermeintliche wahrheit
wieder falsifiziert wird man ein neues
empirisches ergebnis hat zum beispiel
auf quantenebene und dann feststeht ob
die bisher als gültig sagt jetzt mal
nicht war gültig angenommene theorie
müssen wir modifizieren vielleicht nicht
ganz über den haufen werden aber wir
müssen sie modifizieren dass ein anderer
wahrheit' begriff der viel pragmatischer
und die philosophie geht denkt ja nicht
so die philosophie denkt ja er es gibt
natürlich verschiedene vorstellung von
philosophie es gibt auch experimentelle
philosophie aber die metaphysik denkt
jedenfalls so dass sie nicht durch
empirische ergebnisse unbedingt
falsifiziert werden muss
es kann in der metaphysik konkurrierende
ab rio rische systeme geben also systeme
die widerspruchsfreiheit sind konsistent
und sich gleichermaßen vielleicht auch
durch die empirie wir bestätigen lassen
aber das macht der metaphysik jetzt erst
mal nichts
die physik schaut immer nach den
ergebnissen als wir auch noch so ein
punkt weswegen man sagen könnte so was
wie sie und wahrheit' begriff den die
philosophie an nimmt der hat gar keine
geltung in der physik ist wie
pragmatische und sie stellt sich diese
großen fragen vielleicht gar nicht so
sehr
und wenn es eben um raum und zeit und so
weiter geht dann werden metaphysische
themen angesprochen die eben genuines
thema der philosophie sie auch auf der
tradition von der tradition her kommend
kann man ja sagen die physik gibt schon
aristoteles der hatte physik sondern in
grundzügen ersten entwickelt und das war
ein philosoph aristoteles war vielleicht
auch
wissenschaftler aber erster linie hat er
sich als ein philosophie verstanden und
das heißt man könnte auch verweisen auf
die gemeinsame wurzel mit der heutigen
physik und sagen wir sind eben noch ein
bisschen mehr an dieser ursprünglichen
wurzeln dran
das war so ein paar gedanken ich finde
wir müssen die fragen und stellen aber
ich glaube wir haben gute argumente uns
heute etwas mehr gedanken zu machen
über diese relativitätstheorie und ich
habe jetzt hier wieder ein paar fragen
die habe ich auch letzte mal schon
eingestellt gehabt worin besteht der
unterschied zwischen der speziell und
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie weiß
dass dann in der zelle das bezugssystem
welches in die beiden postulat der
speziellen relativitätstheorie wir
wollen also heute nur auf die spezielle
relativitätstheorie behandlungen
was versteht man unter dem
relativitätstheorie dobson konsequenzen
hat die tatsache dass die
lichtgeschwindigkeit überall gleich ist
welche konsequenzen hat die
relativitätstheorie die spezielle und
die allgemeine für unser verständnis von
raum und zeit wie verhält sich die
relativitätstheorie zeit theorien bei
newton und leibnitz haben das letzte mal
schon besprochen da haben wir uns
ausführlich mit beiden nochmal befasst
und wie soll überhaupt philosophen und
philosophen über die ergebnisse für sieg
redet das haben wir jetzt gerade gemacht
als ich bin auch der meinung dass wir
das dürfen dass wir aber immer auch die
möglichen kritikpunkte die physikerinnen
und physiker bringen kann reflektieren
sollten unterlaufen antwort parat haben
sollten
[Musik]
das ist ein guter punkt wir finden dass
viele wichtige physikerinnen und
physiker vor allem füße gerade
allgemeinverständlicher bücher schreiben
wollen ja also die sonst die möglichst
er hat versucht sehr allgemein
verständlich zu schreiben dann von brian
greene das elegante universum
das ist ein bisschen voraussetzung volle
aber auch allgemein verständlich
geschrieben
also das ist ein guter punkt wir finden
dass gerade von den physikern immer mal
wieder versuche unternommen werden die
ergebnisse so darzustellen dass sie
unsere lebenswelt vielleicht auch
betreffen also dass sie zum leihen
hinüber gehen und die relevanz
veranschaulichen wollen die frage ist
natürlich dann immer welche bewertung
diese werke dann in der physik selbst
finden aber ich bin selbst auch der
meinung dass wir unbedingt den dialog
suchen sollten
und sie sagten aber es geht von
physikern haus hin zu den philosophen
und wir gehen jetzt sagen von der
philosophie über jetzt sagen die
physiker die andere richtung die
vielleicht ein bisschen problematischer
ist aber ich will das jetzt einfach mal
offen lassen wir sollten das
reflektieren diese probleme und wenn wir
sie reflektiert haben und gründe
gefunden haben die dafür sprechen und
ich glaube es gibt gründe historische
gründe der verweis auf aristoteles die
ganze philosophie geschichte albert
einstein selbst der eben auch mit ernst
mach einem philosophen und
naturwissenschaftler sich sehr
beschäftigt hatte und eben stärker
systematischen themen frage stellen wir
jetzt die geltung von raum und zeit und
hinterfragten grundvoraussetzung die uns
glaube ich es erlauben mit guten gründen
über physikalische erkenntnisse zu
sprechen
ok jetzt hier mein mein buch das ist
also ich hab mir gesagt einige bücher
jetzt schon mehr angeschaut über die
relativitätstheorie und das ist nach wie
vor mein lieblingsbuch in weil es eben
sehr allgemein verständlich diese diese
relativitätstheorie darstellt und das
ist jetzt eine deutsche übersetzung von
diesem buch und das ist in eine oxford
reihe das also very short introduction
das sind ist eine reihe da sind ganz
verschiedene bände erschienen zum
beispiel auch über zeit über freiheit
ich möchte jetzt demnächst in dieser
reihe buch hat das böse schreiben bin
gespannt ob es angenommen wird
aber es ist sehr gute 3 und das ist eben
die deutsche übersetzung davon und jetzt
gehen wir noch mal einfach auch was mit
dem letzten letzten sitzung schon kurz
angesprochen haben eine kleine
wiederholung also er sagt wir alle
wachsen mit bestimmten grund
vorstellungen über raum zeit und materie
auf darunter den folgen
wir leben alle im selben
dreidimensionalen raum die zeit vergeht
für jedermann gleich schnell
zwei ereignisse treten entweder
gleichzeitig auf oder dass eine findet
vor dem anderen stadt mit genügend
antriebskraft gibt es keine grenze für
die geschwindigkeit einer bewegung
materie kann weder erzeugt noch zerstört
werden
die summe der winkel in einem dreieck
beträgt 180 grad also der raum ist
sozusagen auch irgendwie plan das nicht
gekrümmt
wir haben dann natürlich größere winkeln
einem dreieck wenn der raum gekrümmt ist
plan ist dann haben 180 denken sie sich
eine erdkugel auf der sie einen absolut
kugel auf der sie dreieck zeichnen da
werden sie wie schön das dreieck hatte
mehr als 180 grad nämlich dreimal 90 270
grad
und so weit dann der kreis empfang ist
2p x im radius geht natürlich auch nicht
für gekrümmte räume in einem vakuum
bewegt sich das licht immer geradlinig
natürlich nur dann wenn keine
gravitationskräfte wirken auf das vakuum
es gibt natürlich auch licht ablenkungen
durch gravitation von sternen von
planeten auf die albert einstein schon
hingewiesen hat also man könnte sagen
das ist doch diese ganzen sätze die hier
stehen gehören zum gesunden
menschenverstand das würden wir doch
jetzt einfach mal alle so für wahr
halten es ist intuitiv einläuft
und jetzt sagt der autor solche
vorstellung scheinen wenig mehr als
gesunder menschenverstand zu sein
aber vorsicht die tafel arbeit
einstellen der gesunde menschenverstand
ist die summe der vorurteile die man bis
zu seinem achtzehnten lebensjahr
angesammelt hat und hier kommt glaube
ich gut die philosophie ins spiel die
philosophie besteht darin dass
vermeintlich selbstverständliche das
alltägliche infrage zu stellen
als albert einstein hat hier
letztendlich im philosophischen satz
gesagt es hat auch die karts gemacht das
haben alle großen philosophen und
philosophen war sind wir etwas paradoxes
formuliert und dann hat man gesehen
hoppla wenn man genauer hinschaut auch
wenn es auf den ersten nicht intuitiv
erscheint stellen wir fest dass wenn wir
der sache weiter nachgehen dass es sehr
viel plausibilität hat also durchaus
kritisches denken und der fragen den
gesunden menschenverstand die intuition
nicht für bare münze zu nehmen und das
ist genuin philosophische tätigkeit
würde ich sagen also hier hat mal wieder
so ein bezug zur zu philosophieren
ja
[Musik]
ja also ich glaube man konnte nur diese
ergebnisse berechnen als auch empirisch
dann fassen nachdem man diese spezielle
perspektive auf die welt entworfen hatte
ja das ist wieder das was der
kommilitone sagte hier was wie man eben
die mit der taschenlampe also auch wie
man die die wirklichkeit beleuchtet wie
man sie sich repräsentiert wie man sie
perspektiven und erst dann kommt man ja
zu den interessanten ergebnissen und
dieses perspektiven diesem blickwinkel
auf die welt werfen
das ist nicht nur eine sache der physik
das ist eine wissenschafts theoretische
fragestellung eine meta physikalische
fragestellung oder eben auch
philosophische fragestellung ist die
physik die sich über die perspektiven
auf die welt gedanken macht ist eine
meta wissenschaft die nicht mehr direkt
empirischen ergebnissen zu tun hat und
nicht mehr wirklich rechnet sondern eben
meta reflexion anstellt und insofern
könnte man sagen wäre es ohne physik
durchaus eine philosophie
also wir können erst dann wirklich
rechnen und empirisch verifizierter
falsifizieren genauer gesagt wenn wir
schon uns auf eine perspektive
festgelegt haben und dann stellt sich
die frage welche perspektive werfen wird
auf die welt und diese frage ist jetzt
würde ich sagen nicht mehr eine rein
physikalische fragestellungen und wir
verdanken eben diese perspektive auf die
welt die dann diese ganzen annahmen des
gesunden menschenverstandes modifiziert
hat es sagt sich auf den kopf gestellt
hat darum modifiziert hat und uns zu
ganz interessanten neueren erkenntnissen
gebracht haben zum beispiel die ganzen
satellitensysteme gps und so weiter
fortsetzen voraus die erkenntnisse der
relativität wir könnten nicht
satellitengesteuerte system entwickeln
kein gps empfang haben wenn wir nicht
die ergebnisse der relativitätstheorie
einbezogen hätten unsere theoriebildung
also wie gesagt wirklich lebensweltliche
ganz ganz konkrete praktische folgen
für uns ein alter okay jetzt hatte ich
schon gesagt albert einsteins theorie
hat zwar teile es gibt die spezielle
relativitätstheorie ist man so fünf
formuliert worden in diesem aufsatz über
die elektro dynamik aus den annalen der
physik mit der wir uns heute auch nur
beschäftigen werden weil die allgemeine
ist zu kompliziert
und dann gibt es eben die allgemeine die
elf jahre später erschien albert
einstein war in dieser zeit schon zum
professor des kaiser wilhelms instituts
in berlin ernannt worden zum direktor
sogar heute heißt dieses institut nicht
mehr kaiser im lärms institute sollen
wie wissen sie wie dieses institut heute
heißt max planck institut genau und max
plant ist ein weiterer wichtiger name
max planck war sozusagen der
unmittelbare vorgänger von einstellen
also ein stein hat an max planck
angesetzt an dieser konstante diese
plank konstante größe und jetzt nicht
weiter eingehen und viele hatten die das
geht also um die kleinsten teile und
eine konstante die er dort entdeckt hat
dass eben die energie letztendlich
gewarnt hält ist also das kleinste
energie portionen gibt das hat max
planck behauptet und diese größe ist
eben h also die quandt hält also im
kleinsten einhalten kann man eben
energie auch licht betrachten und albert
einstein hat er direkt angesetzt und
viele andere dachten also was da blank
sagt ist falsch
und vielleicht eine kleine
nebenbemerkung die uns auch jetzt hier
in münchen betrifft also sowohl max
planck als auch albert einstein waren
auf einem münchner gymnasium auch wenn
albert einstein wie sie alle wissen in
ulm geboren ist er war da nur ein paar
monate glaubt fünf monate ganz sind die
eltern nach münchen umgezogen
also hier hat der größten teil seiner
schulbildung genossen auch wenn er dann
mit 16 jahren aus dem gymnasium raus ist
weil sie mir nicht mehr gefallen hat und
hat er in der schweiz hat er dann
weitergemacht
er hat sich dann auch beworben nach
seinem diplom für ganz viele auf ganz
viele assistenten stellen
er meinte von der nordsee bis süditalien
habe er sich beworben auf mitarbeiter
stellen und er kein erfolg hat und dann
ist er zum patentanwalt dritter klasse
gewordene mussten der familie ernähren
und hat dann eben nebenbei sowie auch
kafka seiner recht langweiligen
tätigkeit seine ganzen großen werke
geschrieben hat hat er nebenbei eben mit
freunden auch mit philosophisch
interessierten freunden immer weiter
gedacht und dann eben so seine theorie
entwickelt auch wenn dieser patentanwalt
die patentanwalt stelle nicht zu
unterschätzen weise dritte tat klasse
bedeutet nicht dass das jetzt tritt
klassisch gewesen sei sondern hat er
ordentlich viel geld verdient das war
eine sehr sehr anspruchsvolle tätigkeit
ja das mag auch das weiß ich jetzt nicht
genau das mag ein guter als er hat auf
jeden fall viele einflüsse bekommen
viele anregungen bekommen
in als einer seiner stellen auf jeden
tag waren beide in münchen dann habe ich
glaub maximilians gymnasium also ich
weiß nicht ob sie auch irgendwann aber
also sie haben jedenfalls münchner
schulen genossen
ob das jetzt dazu beigetragen hat dass
sie ihre theorien entwickelt haben ist
eine andere frage
als erste die spezielle
relativitätstheorie handelt von den
wirkungen gleichförmiger bewegungen auf
raum und zeit dass also das sozialsystem
letzteres schließt zusätzlich die
wirkung der beschleunigung und der
schwerkraft rein
erstere ist ein sonderfall der
allumfassenden allgemeine theorie also
die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
enthält die spezielle
relativitätstheorie als einen besonderen
fall
genau also in der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie spielt dann immer
die beschleunigung eine rolle und in der
speziellen nicht da ist es die
gleichförmige bewegung sozusagen
baugleich ist durch t das gilt für die
spezielle relativitätstheorie wissens
sind auch die formel für die
beschleunigung wie ist dvv gleich wenn
es um die beschleunigte bewegungen
da kommt dann das endspiel
nein ich glaube nicht
das wäre glaube ich einmal tee wenn ich
mich nicht täusche frau gleich a x te
also hier dann die beschleunigung genau
aber wir interessieren uns nur für diese
sache hier
für diese gleichförmig beschleunigt
wegen also wenn man das jetzt in einem
koordinatensystem einträgt dann ist es
eben so wenn wir hier die zeit eintragen
und hier die strecke also es dann ist es
eben so je mehr zeit vergangen ist desto
mehr strecke ist vergangenen jahre
zehn jahre bewegung und wenn wir hier
bei der beschleunigten bewegung das im
koordinatensystem hineintragen auch hier
es dann werden wir finden das nicht zu
nehmen derzeit das ganze quadratisch bzw
das ist eben hier steil hoch gehen bei
einer geschleuderten bewegung und das
ist also die betrachten nur solche
geschwindigkeiten jetzt ja
ok jetzt geht es zur speziellen
relativitätstheorie also hier müssen wir
das relativitätstheorie pflichtigen und
die geschwindigkeit und die
geschwindigkeit ist ist das haben sie ja
schon auch gehört jetzt die
geschwindigkeit die lichtgeschwindigkeit
ist konstant ist bei knapp unter 300
tausend kilometer pro sekunde
das heißt sie ist keine beschleunigte
bewegung es geht hier nicht um
beschleunigte bewegung das geht einfach
nur um eben 300 tausend kilometer pro
sekunde also ich mach mal
also ich will jetzt mal die
beschleunigte bewegung weg weil die uns
nicht interessiert
also cdv ist normaler velocity weder
zitat der abkürzung für geschwindigkeit
und er gibt es eben jetzt einen
speziellen fall von der geschwindigkeit
ist ein spezialfall von v und das ist
ungefähr 300 tausend kilometer pro
sekunde
strecke von 1000 kilometern pro sekunde
sind genau genommen 299,95 noch was man
kann sitzt auf rund auf 3000 all das ist
eine ganz konstante geschwindigkeit und
so sieht dann eben diese linie aus also
die raumzeit linie sieht so aus dass
mark schmidt gerade die ursprungs gerade
und hier ist schon termin copski raum
angelegt wir kommen noch mal auf diesen
sogenannten kowski die raumzeit wenn sie
jetzt sich das so denken dass sie das
ganze dreidimensional hier denken also
ein kegel aus dem hier praktisch immer
die kleinen immer so kleine scheiben
hier rein denken dann gibt die
lichtgeschwindigkeit definiert sozusagen
diesen äußeren rand der dieser rand die
sagen die die diese dieser winkel hier
der ist definiert durch die
lichtgeschwindigkeit
das geht dann auch hier natürlich weiter
zurück kann man auch so machen wenn sie
das vorstellen in dem raum zeit scheiden
irland ist definiert durch die
lichtgeschwindigkeit
ok also jetzt geht es um die
lichtgeschwindigkeit und jetzt gehts
gibt's nochmal dieses beispiel das habe
ich auch schon das letzte mal vorgelesen
als sie kennen das alle sie sind in
einem zug sie sitzen im zug am bahnhof
stellen sie sich vor sie befinden sie
dann eisenbahnwaggon deren anbahnung
fällt aus dem fenster sehen sie einen
zweiten zug der neben ihren zug steht
die pfeife des schaffners der
schaffnerin ertönt und schließlich
setzten sie sich in bewegung sanft
gleiten sie an dem anderen zog vorbei
dessen letzte waggon verschwindet an aus
ihrem blickfeld
was ist ihnen ermöglicht zu sehen wie
der bahnhof ebenfalls in der ferne
verschwindet da auch er zurückgelassen
wird nur dass der bahnhof eben nicht
verschwindet er bleibt einfach an der
alten stelle und bewegt sich nirgendwo
hin
genauso wie sie im zug sitzen und sich
nirgendwo hin bewegen
allmählich dämmert es ihnen dass sie
sich überhaupt nicht bewegt haben der
andere zog war ist der sich vor bewegt
hat also
das kennen sie bestimmt als mäßig ein
paar mal so ne das ist eine simple
beobachtung manchmal lassen wir uns auf
uns alle auf diese weise täuschen in
wahrheit können sie nicht entscheiden ob
sie sich wirklich bewegen oder nicht
zumindest dann nicht wenn es sich um
eine konstante gleichförmige bewegung
geraten mit bewegung handelt also es ist
ja so in dem zug ist es so wenn sie
anfahren und sind auch mal schnell
anfahren und im auto ist vielleicht noch
besser dann merken sie dass es sie
zurück drückt also wenn sie und sie
starten und oder auch beschleunigen im
auto dann drückt sie es zurück das ist
also die trägheit kraft dann merken sie
gravitationskräfte an sich wirken und
sie merken anhand dieser kraft die auf
sie wirkt das hier sind der oder die
sich bewegt das ist bei einer
gleichförmigen geschwindigkeit nicht der
fall
wenn sie also gleichförmig fahren oder
bemerken sie draußen geschieht was
anderes was gleichförmig ist dann haben
sie da kein kriterium sagen was jetzt
eigentlich sich bewegt normalerweise
wenn sie etwa mit dem auto reisen wissen
sie dass sie sich bewegen selbst wenn
sie die augen geschlossen haben können
sie fühlen wie sie verschiedene
richtungen gedrückt werden
zum beispiel gehen sie die kurve wird
die zentrale zentrifugalkräfte das habe
auch beschleunigungskräfte kräfte
beschleunigen wenn sie ansetzen
selbst werden sie die augen geschlossen
haben können sie fühlen wie sie
verschiedene richtung gedrückt werden
wenn der wagen um kurven und über
schlaglöcher fährt plötzlich
beschleunigt oder bremst wenn abbremst
dann drückt sie ist nach vorne
auch die trägheit kraft arbeitet ein
flugzeug das konstant dahin gleitet
hätten sie abgesehen von dem
motorengeräusch und die leichten
vibration keine möglichkeit zu
entscheiden ob sie sich bewegen oder
nicht das leben innerhalb des flugzeugs
verläuft genau so als ob das flugzeug
auf der erde stehen würde
wir sagen dass das flugzeug ein ideales
bezugssystem darstellt damit meinen wir
dass sich juden streek heitz gesetze
anwenden lassen das heißt dass ein von
diesen bezugssystem aus betrachtet der
gegenstand weder seine geschwindigkeiten
auch seine richtung ändern wird wenn
keine unausgeglichene kraft auf ihn wird
beispielsweise bleibt ein von ihnen auf
dem ablage tisch denen das wasser klar
an diesem ort wie sie es mit ihrer hand
bewegen
also wir haben jetzt hier
ein flugzeug sie haben jetzt hier im
flugzeug drin
das ist jetzt das flugzeug und jetzt
haben wir hier einen tisch und haben ein
wasserglas
und wenn das flugzeug jetzt in diese
richtung fliegt bleibt dieses wasserglas
immer auf dem tisch ist bleibt immer auf
dem tisch es erinnert nicht sein ein ort
auf dem tisch und genauso auch wenn sie
jetzt hier was runterfallen lassen hier
landet das sie lassen was runterfallen
kugeln gegenstand die fliegenden
flugzeug zu lassen was runter fallen ist
vielleicht schon mal vorgekommen dass
sie was im flugzeug aus sind auf dem
boden haben fallen lassen und dann
werden sie feststellen dass landet genau
unterhalb des ortes an dem sie die
gegenstand losgelassen haben
wenn sie das jetzt von außen betrachten
also der grund ist der dass alles sich
in diesem flugzeug mit derselben
geschwindigkeit bewegt deswegen können
sie eigentlich die geschwindigkeit
abziehen sie können dir ausrechnen sie
können sagen es steht und sich alles
gleichmäßig bewegt und dann bewegt sich
die tasse identisch der tisch bewegt
sich identisch da können sie so so das
ganze ansehen als ob es sich nicht
bewegen wird als ob es war ja alles
dieselbe geschwindigkeit haben wenn sie
jetzt hingegen der tisch ein bisschen
schneller bewegen würden und die taste
langsamer sie haben dann sähe es schon
anders aus also das ist sagen das
sozialsystem es gibt denn
es gibt natürlich kräfte die auf dieses
flugzeug wirken wenn sie sich ganz
gerade wenig bewegt konstant dann werden
die kräfte ausgeglichen sie wissen ja
kräfte wenn sie entgegengesetzt wirken
kräfte beschreibt man durch pfeile
dann heben sie sich auf wenn die beträge
der kräfte genau gleich groß sind dann
heben sie sich auf
der bahnhof entfernt
eigentlich stehe weil er sie denn nicht
entfernt also das wäre
wien
stationen des kanals werde ich
tatsächlich das so war
ich stehe der anderen zug verlegt sind
und der bahnhof verschwindet oder ein
kleiner mensch
ich würde sagen das ist enorm das
bestellung
ja das ist ja tags ist glaube ich
ironisch der text zero nisch also sagt
eben wie der bahnhof in der ferne
verschwindet er zurückgelassen wird und
dann kommt eben hier
diese dieses nur da sich der bahnhof
eben nicht das eben nicht verschmäht als
wir auch den eindruck dass das kleine
wenn wir das wäre interessant weil ja
also ich weiß nicht wie es lag also ich
glaube schon also man denkt jetzt
sozusagen jetzt bewegt also der zug
sagen wir hätten wir lassen jetzt den
zug vorbei wir fahren ein zug vorbei bzw
und das ganze sein wir lassen den zug
hinter uns und dann müsste auch der
bahnhof hinter uns verschwinden und ja
dass das problem ist nur mit der
wahrnehmungspsychologie dass es eben
dann nichts mehr mit der
relativitätstheorie zu tun hat also
dann nämlich genau in dem moment war
wenn ich sehe dass der markt eigentlich
sich nicht verändert was ich halt nicht
mehr
das ist richtig das problem ist nur bei
diesen relativitätstheorie nicht sicher
sagen können ob sich nicht doch auch der
bahnhof bewegt weil natürlich die erde
bewegt sich ja auch also der bahnhof ist
sozusagen selbst wenn sie jetzt an ihm
vorbeifahren dann haben sie relativ zum
bahnhof bewegen sie sich das ist klar
er lernt sie können sie messen ihre
bewegung am ruhenden bahnhof aber es
könnte ja auch sein dass der bahnhof an
ihnen vorbeizieht
weil die erde sich bewegt und sie jetzt
zu sagen die erde unter ihnen beck fehlt
da war noch eine meldung
ja
ja also es ist so man kann natürlich
relativ gemessen wenn es könnte auch so
sein theoretisch dass der bahnhof sich
tatsächlich irgendwie weg bewegt er ist
natürlich nicht so also der bahnhof ruth
natürlich theoretisch wäre es möglich in
diesem system das sie immer noch in
diesem zug sagen ruhender sitzt und das
praktisch nur die schienen unter dem zug
dass die sich weg bewegen also dass der
zug gut aber die erde unter ihnen sich
sozusagen zurück dreht das können sie
eigentlich gar nicht entscheiden dass
das problem und die erde dreht sich ja
auch also sagen wenn sie auf der erde
hier brauchen wir die gleiche krümmung
wenn sie hier mit dem zug fahren dass
der zug geht es hier der zug bewegt sich
hierhin bewegt sich das dazu dass die
erde her und die erde bewegt sich ja
auch dann addieren sich die
geschwindigkeiten also sie ich weiß mit
wifi km h das kann man ausrechnen
ich glaube die erde bewegt sich mit 500
mit 5000 kilometer pro stunde glaube
nicht bewegte sich also wir alle bewegen
uns in diesem raum wir haben mindestens
werden noch mehr kamen hat auf wir
bewegen uns relativ zu einem zum
beispiel zum anderen neutralen
beobachter im weltraum der die erde
drehen sieht bewegen wir uns mit einer
geschwindigkeit glaube ich von 5000
kilometer pro stunde
ja also erhalten
das ist immerhin schon in frage gestellt
doch nicht
die daten
ja also ich lese es eben so dass ich
lese diesen text so dass wir erwarten
dass wir uns bewegen
dabei bewegt sich eben der andere zug
und als der andere zug vorbei ist nehmen
wir an der bahnhof würde auch von uns
zurückgelassen werden
aber er bewegt sich nicht weil ja also
ein wichtiger punkt ich möchte mich
jetzt aber auch nicht so lange daran
jetzt aufhalten
genau genau also deswegen möchte jetzt
weitergehen
genauso aber was aber was geschieht wenn
sie aus dem flugzeugfenster blick und
sehen wie die erde unter ihnen vorbei
gleitet sagt ihnen das nicht dass ich
das flugzeug bewegt nicht wirklich
schließlich ist die erde nicht stationär
sie bewegt sich auf einer umlaufbahn um
die sonne
die sonne selbst befindet sich auf einer
umlaufbahn um das zentrum der
milchstraße galaxy und die milchstraße
galaxy bewegt sich innerhalb einer
anhäufung von ähnlichen galaxien
wir können nur sagen dass diese bewegung
alle relativ sind das flugzeug bewegt
sich relativ zur erde die erde bewegt
sich relativ zum flugzeug es gibt keine
möglichkeit zu entscheiden wer
tatsächlich unbewegt ist jeder der sich
gleich für mich relativ zu einem runden
anderen bewegt ist berechtigt sich
selbst als ruhend und die andere person
als bewegt zu betrachten das ist deshalb
so weil die naturgesetze die regeln die
alle ereignisse reagieren
für jeden der sich in konstanter
gleichförmiger bewegung befindet das
heißt für jeden denn einen initialen
bezugssystem ist die selben sind das ist
das relativität also was ist nochmal
initialen system
er würde sogar kurz anfassen
was ist denn jetzt jahres ziehen es
könnte also wichtig man könnte jetzt
sagen
ein system in dem kann dem keine kräfte
wirken das wäre aber nicht ganz exakt
weil es könnte ein system sein auf das
kräfte wirken aber die kräfte so darauf
wirken dass die kräfte sich aufheben
also ein unterschied also kräfte werden
immer mit pfeilen angezeigt und wir
haben ein betrag der gt bis zur spitze
des pfeil ist wenn ich jetzt hier ein
system habe und die kraft würde also
praktisch von links auf dieses system
drücken
dann hätte ich eine beschleunigte
bewegung weil er immer derselbe betrag
auf diesen gegen auf dieses objekt wird
und dann setzt sich in bewegung und weil
zu jedem neuen geschwindigkeits punkt
wieder dieselbe kraft ansetzt kommen wir
zu einer beschleunigten bewegung
es gibt also eine seine koffer schon
also das wäre keine soziale system wenn
wir hier immer eine kraft an einem punkt
ansetzen die permanenten dann bekommen
wir eine beschleunigte bewegung so was
als wenn wir hier
th und dann bekommen wir hier so eine
beschleunigte bewegung
und wenn jetzt aber hier noch eine kraft
wird und zwar mit demselben betrag dann
heben die sich auf da haben wir es ist
also völlig richtig mann dürfte jetzt
sagen ein system in dem keine
beschleunigungskräfte wirken damit ist
auch impliziert dass kräfte wirken aber
ebenso dass ich aufgeben es muss ein
gleichförmig bewegtes system sein und
alle die all diesen systemen gelten
dieselben naturgesetzen dieselben
jüdischen naturgesetz als ein gegenstand
feld gleichmäßig zu boden mit derselben
geschwindigkeit auf sie
das ist schon aber ich meinte jetzt eben
also der beschleunigte gegenstand der
ist dann nicht das sozialsystem sind der
findet in einem sozialsystem stadt genau
richtig aber aber eben das system in dem
dieser gegenstand fällt also es geht
jetzt sagen nur um diesen diesen rahmen
der sich bewegt und nicht um das was da
drin sich tun in dem rahmen drin gelten
alle newtonschen gesetze auf dieselbe
weise allen naturgesetzen eben auch die
gravitationskraft man also sagen nicht
der gegenstand der jetzt runter fällt
der ist nicht das soziale system könnte
ja irgendwie ein gegenstand so eine
kapsel runterfallen lassen dann wäre das
selbst keinen sozialsystem weil es eben
beschleunigt passiert aber alles was
sich innerhalb eines gleichmäßigen
beschleunigten er gleichmäßig bewegt und
systems vollzieht für das gelten
dieselben naturgesetzen nach juden
sie müssen davon ausgehen dass es hier
um gleichmäßig belegte und einer
gleichen geschwindigkeit erfolgende
systeme gehen dann haben sie es um oder
mit hunden das ist unrunde systeme gehen
wenn sich die kräfte sozusagen aufheben
kann natürlich auch an einen gegenstand
sein der sich mit einer gleichmäßigen
geschwindigkeit bewegt an dem zwei
gleich als die entgegengesetzte kräfte
wirken dann dann fliegt er natürlich
weiter mit derselben konstanten
geschwindigkeit wenn er schon einmal
davon bewegung waren aber es könnte auch
unruhen das runde system sein das nicht
bewegt ist und auf das auch zwei gleich
große kräfte einwirken die sich aber
weiß ich genau entgegengesetzt sind
aufheben dann haben wir auch mit einem
sozialsystem zu tun also es geht nur
darum dass ich diese dieses system nicht
beschleunigt bewegt sind dass es sich
gleichmäßig das ist in der 10
und jetzt geht es weiter und tatsächlich
war es nicht ein stein der dieses
prinzip des sonnen es geht auf galileo
zurück wenn das so ist warum wurde dann
das wort relativität mit den namen von
einstein verbunden einstellen bemerkt
dass sich unter den naturgesetzen
wechsels gesetze des elektromagnetismus
befanden maxwells zufolge ist licht eine
form elektromagnetische strahlung daher
ist es möglich aufgrund der erkenntnisse
der stärke elektrische und magnetische
kräfte die lichtgeschwindigkeit c in
einem vakuum zu berechnen die tatsache
dass licht eine geschwindigkeit besitzt
leuchtet nicht unmittelbar ein
wenn sich wenn sie sich in einer
abgedunkelten wenn sich ein
abgedunkeltes zimmer begeben und eine
lampe einschalten scheint das licht
augenblicklich überall zu sein
an der decke an den wänden und auf dem
fußboden also sofort der ganze raum
aber das stimmt nicht das licht braucht
zeit um von der glühbirne oder jetzt der
neonröhre zu seinem bestimmungsort zu
wandern nicht viel zeit es ist zu
schnell als dass man die verzögerung mit
bloßem auge erkennen könnte nach diesem
naturgesetz beläuft sich die
lichtgeschwindigkeit c in einem vakuum
auf 299 1199 299 1700 92,4 58 kilometer
pro sekunde oder mit einem sehr kleinen
unterschied in der luft mal ruft
wiederum kein vakuum ist also moleküle
enthält durch die das licht eben leicht
gebremst das ist also das ergebnis der
geschwindigkeitsmessung
also c die lichtgeschwindigkeit ist
konstant also frau gleich es durch t
wir haben es also wenn es um
lichtgeschwindigkeit geht mit nicht
beschleunigen bewegung zu tun sollen wir
haben hier eine konstante und deswegen
können wir mit der lichtgeschwindigkeit
erst mal auch nur in sozialsysteme
operieren die die spezielle
relativitätstheorie und betreffen also
licht ist nichts was unendlich schnell
ist das der erste punkt licht ist eine
konstante lichtgeschwindigkeit ist fix
es gibt eine absolute zahl die das ein
maß das dass die geschwindigkeit misst
und ein weiterer punkt ist licht bedarf
keines etats also keines mediums in dem
es sich bewegen kann das ist jetzt der
nächste punkt also einmal schon richtig
licht ist nicht unendlich schnell nicht
hat eine endliche geschwindigkeit
jetzt kommt das andere was geschieht nun
wenn sich an die lichtquelle bewegt man
könnte zum beispiel warten da sich das
licht wie eine granate verhält die von
einem vorbeifahrenden kriegschiff
abgefeuert wurde
ein beobachter am meeresufer würde
erwarten dass die geschwindigkeit des
schiffes sich zu der mündung
geschwindigkeit der granate hinzu
addieren würde wenn sie nach vorne
abgefordert wird und abgezogen werden
würde wenn die granate vom heck
abgeführt wird
1964 wurde das verhalten des lichts in
dieser hinsicht im genfer cern
laboratorium überprüft indem man winzige
subatomare partikel verwendete die
neutrale ionen genannt werden die polen
die sich mit 0,9 99 75 c von wegen also
knapp im noch ein bisschen weniger als
290.000 zerfielen unter abstrahlung in
zwei lichtimpulsen man fand heraus dass
beide pulse innerhalb der
messgenauigkeit von 0,1 prozent die
übliche lichtgeschwindigkeit aufwiesen
also hängt die lichtgeschwindigkeit
nicht von der geschwindigkeit decke ab
das ist auch noch mal interessant
also
mit dem licht als noch was auf sich und
das hängt damit sozusagen das ist in
keinem medium eines mediums bedarf also
wir haben jetzt hier nehme mal an wir
haben beziehen
ein kampfjet machen wir mal so hier so
gepflegt mit einer konstanten
geschwindigkeit dieser jetzt mal v1 und
diese kampfjet der schießt hier eine
rakete ab zwar am flügel einer rakete
und die schießt jetzt ab und die
geschwindigkeit dieses dieser rakete sei
22 wie erscheint jetzt die
geschwindigkeit dieser rakete diese
rakete aus dem cockpit heraus
wie sieht das jetzt der pilot die
pilotin wie schnell bewegt sich die
pakete von ihm vor
genau als ich sagen wir mal so mit v2
und v2 ist größer als v1 natürlich als
wird hinzuaddiert jedenfalls von ihm aus
gesehen ist die geschwindigkeit
ich weiß nicht wie viel wenn sie mal ein
video gesehen haben wo soll aus dem
kampfjet eine rakete abgefeuert wird
erscheint es aus dem piloten cockpit
heraus schätzt mal grob genommen wie
vielleicht 100 km h oder so wie sich die
die rakete von dem piloten aus nach
vorne liegt 100 km/h vielleicht 200 km h
ich weiß nicht genau so und jetzt
betrachten sie das ganze immer nicht aus
der perspektive des cockpits aus der
perspektive der erde
sie sehen jetzt wieder ein kampfjet über
ihn drüber fliegt und erschießt eine
rakete noch ab wie groß ist dann die
geschwindigkeit der rakete abgeschossen
wird so groß wie die geschwindigkeit des
kampfjets schluss noch mal die
geschwindigkeit mit der sie sich
zusätzlich bewegt also die die rakete
die ihre geschwindigkeit sagen die
alleinige abschluss geschwindigkeit
addiert so auf die geschwindigkeit mit
der sie eh schon bewegt wurde
sie müssen sich vorstellen die rakete
die am flügel ist die hat schon die
geschwindigkeit des kampfjets und dann
wird sie noch zusätzlich abgeschossen
und addiert sich diese geschwindigkeit
der kampfpilot sieht nur die eigene
geschwindigkeit die die sagen wir
relativ zu ihm hat und die ist jetzt
nicht so groß vielleicht 100 gramm also
geschwindigkeit addieren sich ne oder
anders gesagt wenn sie sie befinden sich
auf einem schiff auf dem schiff was ich
mit der geschwindigkeit mit der
geschwindigkeit von hier ist und wasser
haben ihren schiff und das schiff hat
eine geschwindigkeit von 120 km/h
pro sekunde in diese richtung und sie
werfen jetzt auf diesem schiff werfen
sie jetzt eben ein ball einmal werfen
sie auch in dieselbe richtung wie sich
das schiff wieder schiff fährt dann wird
aus ihrer perspektive mit der sie sich
auf dem schiff befinden der ball die
geschwindigkeit haben mit dem sie in
werfen wir mal 10 km h von ihrer
perspektive auf dem schiff hat der ball
die geschwindigkeit mit dem hinwerfen
werden sie jetzt aber das ganze von
außen betrachten hat der ball die
geschwindigkeit mit der sie werfen also
10 km h schluss die geschwindigkeit mit
der sich das schiff bewegt wenn sie das
ganze von außen betrachtung vom festland
aus addieren sich die geschwindigkeiten
aber jetzt könnte man annehmen mit dem
licht verhält sich genauso
also werden sie zum beispiel jetzt mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit fliegen wenn sie
mit lichtgeschwindigkeit fliegen und
dann mit dieser und auf dieser
lichtgeschwindigkeit also ein raumschiff
an dass ich mit lichtgeschwindigkeit weg
und in diesem raum schiffen noch mal mit
einer pistole nach vorne schießen
dass dann die geschwindigkeit der
pistolenkugel sich zu der
geschwindigkeit addiert mit der das rad
unterwegs ist und das geht eben nicht
sagt albert einstein es gibt keine
geschwindigkeit die größer ist als die
lichtgeschwindigkeit also die
geschwindigkeit bleibt überall konstanz
diesen absolute grenze
es ist ein ganz wichtiger weitere
eigenschaft des lichts kommen da nicht
weiter die geschwindigkeiten addieren
sich nicht in dieser logik des lichts
also nochmal hier zurück bei einem
schiff addieren sich die
geschwindigkeiten wenn es schon fährt
plus die kanone die geschwindigkeit
addieren sich und man hat jetzt im cern
diesem genfer laboratorium festgestellt
das ist nicht zuletzt dass die
geschwindigkeiten sich nicht über die
geschwindigkeit des lichts agieren
können sie hängt die geschwindigkeit
hängt auch nicht davon ab ob man annimmt
dass der beobachtete das licht sich
bewegt oder nicht betrachten wir noch
einmal den fall eines sich bewegenden
schiffs da wir schon festgestellt haben
das licht sich nicht wie eine granate
verhält die von einer kanone abgefeuert
wird könnten wir möglicherweise erwarten
dass sie sich so verhält wie wellen auf
dem wasser befindet der beobachte sich
nun auf einem sich bewegenden brot würde
sich die wellenfront vor dem boot
langsam wegen langsamer zu bewegen
scheinen als die welt front die sich
nach hinten ausbreitet wegen der
bewegung des bootes und seiner selbst
relativ zum waschen da man jetzt hier
ein
die grafik also wählen die von einem
boot ausgesetzt hand werden scheint sich
für einen beobachter auf dem boot
langsam nach vorne zu bewegen als nach
hinten was ist jetzt vorne was es hinten
da bin ich ein bisschen durcheinander
kommen wo es jetzt vorne hier auf den
boden wo es hinten ist das vorne und das
hinten
da hat jemand kopf geschüttet
also das ist langsamer als unklar
formuliert vorne könnte man denken ist
das hier aber vorne ist aber die boots
richtung
alles klar also wir bewegen uns hier weg
von der ausbreitung nach da und weil wir
uns weg bewegen scheint sich das
schneller zu wegner und die langsam nach
vorne aus der sicht des bootes was wir
hingegen die wir jetzt außen stehen für
die bewegt sich das natürlich gleich
schnell bewegen sich die wellen gleichen
beide bewegungen
das ist der macht perfekt ernst mach
diese hürde so von naturwissenschaftler
von dem ich schon erzählt hatte in dem
sich albert einstein sehr beschäftigt
hatte der hat diesen effekt der
überlagerung von zwei geschwindigkeiten
sagte erst mal geschrieben sie können
diesen mass effect einfach auch am
schalter effekt ganz einfach
nachvollziehen wenn sie zum beispiel
einen polizeiwagen sie ruhen sie
befinden sich an der straße sie sehen
ein polizeiauto auf sie zukommen an sich
vorbeifahren
dann hören sie dass sich der signalton
in seiner höhe ändern
ich kenne diese typischen polizeisirenen
effekt es wird ich weiß nicht wie es
wird irgendwie höher und dann wird es
wieder tiefer der ton also auf eine
bestimmte weise verändert sich das und
das ist der macht effekt also es geht
eben darum dass das die
geschwindigkeiten einmal addiert werden
und einmal substrat werden also wenn das
auto auf sie zukommt dann ist die
frequenz höher weil sich das ganze
addiert wenn es von ihnen weg fährt dann
haben wir hier eben diesen effekt dass
das ganze sich langsam zu geben scheint
es ist ja so gerne macht effekt also
praktisch bewegte quellen von von wellen
und jetzt könnte man annehmen licht
verhält sich genauso wie zum beispiel
schallwellen dass sie abhängig sind von
der bewegung der quelle also wenn sie
zum beispiel eine glühbirne der
glühbirne die licht ausstrahlt im raum
bewegen und die glut wurde auf sie zu
kommt ja dann könnte man denken das
licht kommt jetzt eben schneller
entgegen wenn sie eine glühbirne auf sie
zu bewegen weil das licht wird ja mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit von der glühbirne
ausgesandt und dann bewegte die
glühbirne noch zusätzlich zu ihnen das
heißt sie könnten sagen die glühbirne
machen wir kurz das vielleicht noch
besseres beispiel sie haben jetzt hier
eine glühbirne die man ja gar nicht mehr
jetzt haben darf mit dem weltrat und
jetzt haben sie hier nicht
geschwindigkeit wird ausgesandt und zwar
in alle richtungen natürlich ist klar
aber uns interessiert jetzt nur diese
richtung wir sind hier wir sind wir
das ist dass das licht das ist sie und
jetzt könnten sie aber annehmen
die glühbirne selbst wird auch bewegt
die glühbirne wird jetzt bewegt mit vhv
und dann müsste eigentlich das licht was
bei ihnen ankommt also das müsste
eigentlich die geschwindigkeit c haben +
form weil es ja noch zusätzlich bewegt
wird weil die glühbirne sich ja noch das
heißt eigentlich müsste das licht was
bei ihnen ankommt
überlichtgeschwindigkeit haben weil sie
eine bewegte nicht gelernt wenn die
prüfer neben bewegt ist und dass es
dieses beispiel mit dem kanonen bodens
und da sagt einstein oder die eine der
konsequenzen waren stand ist nein
selbst wenn die lichtquelle bewegt ist
addieren sich geschwindigkeit nicht auf
die lichtgeschwindigkeit auf die bleibt
konstant selbst wenn diese quelle bewegt
ist dieses addition sully zions prinzip
gilt nicht bei lichtgeschwindigkeit
und das ist praktisch der schlüssel zum
verständnis der ganzen relativiert
speziellen relativitätstheorie dass sich
geschwindigkeiten nicht addiert
lassen auf die lichtgeschwindigkeit
darauf dass die die quelle kann so
schnell bewegt sein wie man möchte
sie wird sich nicht zur
lichtgeschwindigkeit addieren das licht
bleibt egal wie schnell die bewegte
quelle ist wie geht es natürlich von
gleichförmig bewegten system aus wir
gehen von sozialsystem auswendig
beschleunigen system aber sie wird eben
dieselbe bleiben und das ist schon mal
zum beispiel contra intuitiv das würde
uns im gesunden menschenverstand jetzt
erstmal zuwiderlaufen weil wir sagen
würden
wieso sollte sich nicht anders verhalten
als wenn es ein bewegtes objekt ist wenn
vertonen oder die kleinsten nicht zahlen
wenn die nimmt meine geschwindigkeit
haben wieso sollte sich der und
geschwindigkeitsverhalten anders
verhalten als kanonenkugeln oder als
delle die wir auf schiffen werden warum
denn warum das ist doch völlig konto
intuitiv zunächst mal dass der gesunde
menschenverstand der jetzt hier in frage
gestellt wird und jetzt gehts weiter
angenommen licht ist eine welle die sich
durch ein medium bewegt das den ganzen
rahmen durchdringt ein medium das
behelfsweise täter genannt wurde
dann sollten wir da die erde sich ihren
weg durch den äther band feststellen
dass die lichtgeschwindigkeit relativ zu
uns beobachten die wir uns gemeinsam mit
der erde bewegen in verschiedenen
richtungen verschieben ist also wir
senden nicht einmal als wir haben jetzt
hier die erde
die erde und die dreht sich jetzt mal
ihr und wenn wir jetzt hier in den
körper haben und die körper der sendet
licht in diese richtung in dieser
richtung
dann sollte das licht in der richtung in
die sich auch die erde dreht schneller
sein als in diese richtung weil sich ja
die bilder auch noch hier mit der er das
ist also
aber in einem berühmten experiment das
von michael maul in 1887 durchgeführt
wurde stellte man fest dass die
lichtgeschwindigkeit in allen richtungen
dieselbe ist
die lichtgeschwindigkeit ist also
unabhängig davon ob die quelle oder der
beobachter als bewegt angesehen werden
und dieses experiment von michaels und
molly das ist ein sowie das experiment
zum crucis lesen
wissen sie was ein experiment um kurz es
ist also ein kreuzes experiment das ist
ein experiment was eigentlich etwas
belegen sollte also eigentlich die
theorie die man angenommen hatte belegen
sollte dass aber gerade die theorie für
falsch erklärt hatte unbewusst
unbeabsichtigt also experiment was etwas
belegen sollte es aber gerade nicht
belegt hat soll miterlebt hat und dieses
experiment zeigte eben das licht nicht
so zu denken ist wie zum beispiel schale
der ein medium braucht luft zum beispiel
im vakuum können sie nichts wenn sie
jetzt alles wenn sie ein vakuum zeugen
und keine luftmoleküle mehr hier in
diesem raum haben dann können sie doch
so laut schreien und man hört nichts
fall braucht ein medium um sich bewegen
zu können überhaupt auftreten zu können
und beim licht ist es eben anders licht
verhält sich nicht nicht wählen
verhalten sich nicht so wie schallwellen
dass sie ein medium brauchen in einem
medium wäre es so dass ich dann
geschwindigkeiten agieren würden ist der
punkt
also wenn wir jetzt hier ein medium
ansetzen würden in dem sich das nicht
bewegt dann würden sich die
geschwindigkeiten addieren dann wäre es
tatsächlich so dass die erd-
geschwindigkeit auf die
lichtgeschwindigkeit addiert würde wenn
es ein medium gebe und das medium von
dem man dachte dass es das gäbe in dem
sich das licht bewegen kann
das nannte man damals älter das war so
der name dafür etr man wusste aber nicht
was ist jetzt der eltern und dieses
experiment von michaels und mollis
sollte beweisen dass es ein echter gibt
und man dachte eben okay wenn es ein
älter gibt dann muss das licht in diese
richtung in die sich die erde bewegt
schneller bewegen und in der anderen
richtung langsamer man hatte eben
gemessen da sich in beide richtung genau
gleich schnell bewegt und damit konnte
man dann die hypothese des täters
falsifizieren und das war das experiment
um cruz ist also das war ganz wichtig
[Musik]
das ist so bei ist es so dass wurde er
ganz zu beginn gesagt dass die photonen
also die theilig teilchen dass die wenn
sie auf atome treffen ein bisschen
abgebremst werden das dann so ein
physikalischer effekt aber im vakuum
sozusagen die vakuum bewegt sich mit der
konstanten geschwindigkeit als wenn sie
jetzt hier so war kaum annehmen würden
in dem sich die erde dreht sie ist
natürlich nicht richtig im vakuum aber
nehmen sie mal an das universum ist ja
recht leer
sie haben da ein stern oder einem
planeten der sich dreht im vakuum und
sie sind von diesem sich bewegte körper
eine lichtquelle aus dem vakuum dann
addieren sich die geschwindigkeit nicht
oder sie selbst werden auch nicht
substantiiert wenn subtrahiert wenn wir
die andere richtung betrachten
nicht nicht nicht als es bleibt immer
konstant das ist der punkt unabhängig
von den anderen bewegungen dass diese
tradition prinzip gilt nicht und war
deswegen nicht weil es kein medium gibt
in dem sich dass das nicht bewegt und
das ist sagen die die ganz wichtige
voraussetzungen wie gelang also zu
folgendem
erstens dem relativität prinzip das
besagt dass die naturgesetze für alle
initialen bezugssystem dieselben sind
also eben auch newtons
gravitationsgesetz war der punkt fuhren
also dass newtonsche gravitationstheorie
station ins gesetz ist jetzt wenn wir
den vereinen gegenstand betrachten
natürlich dann ist es keine soziale
systeme aber in allen in sozialen system
gelten dieselben natur das jetzt eben
auch die beschleunigungs gesetze und
zweitens dem wert der
lichtgeschwindigkeit in ein vakuum der
aufgrund dieser gesetze berechnet werden
kann dieser wert ist in allen sozialen
zug system derselbe unabhängig von der
jeweiligen geschwindigkeit der quelle
oder das beobachter ist also das
addition prinzip von geschwindigkeiten
gilt nicht mehr
in diesem falle das licht ist und zwar
deswegen weil es kein medium gibt in dem
sich das nicht bewegen muss kein träger
wie zum beispiel die luft für den
schaden diese beiden aussagen werden die
beiden postulate oder grundprinzipien
der speziellen relativitätstheorie
genannt und wurden als solche bekannt
als uns interessiert vor allem das
zweite
der zweite punkt das geben die
lichtgeschwindigkeit nicht wie größer
werden kann wenn sie sich auf einem
träger sei diesmal bewegen und das ist
dann auch für unsere rechnung auf unsere
kleine rechnung die wir jetzt anstellen
wollen gleich in schwung gekommen
diese tatsache gehalten diese tatsachen
galten unter physikern lange zeit als
allgemeingut es bedurfte des genies von
albert einstein um zu erkennen dass
obwohl jeder beiden aussagen sinnvoll
war wenn man sie gesondert betrachtet
sie keinen sinn zu ergeben schien immer
die beiden gedanken das anfühlt wenn die
erste aussage war ist schien es dass die
zweite falsch oder wenn die zweite
richtig war die erste falsch sein muss
wenn beide richtig sind was wir
anscheinend festgestellt haben man muss
etwas sehr wichtiges nicht stimmen
die tatsache dass die
lichtgeschwindigkeit für alle inertial
beobachte unabhängig von der bewegung
der quelle oder des beobachters dieselbe
ist bedeutet dass unser gewöhnliches
verfahren der addition und substraktion
fündig
keinen fall schluss das ist dieses
beispiel mit dieser erde auf der sich
eine lichtquelle mit dass die also
falsch ist und wenn mit uns am begriff
von geschwindigkeit die schlicht die
entfernung geteilt durch zeit ist
baugleich ist durch t bei gleichförmigen
geschwindigkeiten also gar nicht
beschleunigen etwas nicht stimmt dann
folgt wieder daraus wiederum das etwas
mit uns im begriff des raumes oder
derzeit oder bei dem verkehr ziehen muss
wir haben es hier nicht mit irgendeiner
besonderheit des lichts oder
elektromagnetische strahlung zu tun
alles was ich mit derselben
geschwindigkeit wie das nicht fortbewegt
wird für alle initialen beobachter diese
denselben wert im hinblick auf seine
geschwindigkeit haben entscheidend ist
die geschwindigkeit und die folgerung
für den zurück liegenden raum und die
zeit nicht die tatsache dass erst
zufällig mit licht zu tun haben also
ganz wichtig hier dass das verfahren der
addition dass das eben nicht gilt
normalerweise kann man geschwindigkeiten
addieren
hier geht es eben nicht und jetzt kommen
wir zur zeit die nation als zeit
ausdehnung um zu sehen was hier nicht
stimmen stellen sie sich eine
astronautin einem hochgeschwindigkeits
raumschiff vor und eine person in einer
weltraum kontrollstation auf der erde
beide haben identische uhren die
astronautin soll ein einfaches
experiment durchführen
auf dem boden des traumschiffs sollen
sie eine lampe befestigen die einen
lichtimpuls aussehen und nach oben der
puls wandert direkt nach oben im rechten
winkel zur bewegungsrichtung des
raumschiffs dort trifft der puls auf
eine zielscheibe die an der decke
befestigt ist
nehmen wir an dass das raumschiff vier
meter hoch ist das licht das sich mit
der geschwindigkeit c knapp 3000
kilometer pro sekunde ausbreitet stellt
die astronautin fest dass die zeit t
strich lichtpuls wird diese reise
braucht anhand der messung ihrer uhr
hier strich gleich vier meter durch die
lichtgeschwindigkeit beträgt also sagen
wir hier dieses bild
also sehen das ist aus der perspektive
der astronautin in diesem raumschiff
sie haben jetzt hier die lichtquelle
unten und der weg ist eben vier metern
und sie können dann eben die zeit
ausrechnen nach dieser formel hier ist
dann es durch v
wenn ich das so um form habe ich dann
als auch mal dass wochen habe es dort
also t wäre eben vier meter durch die
durchziehen dann haben sie diese diese
zeit die das licht braucht um nach oben
zu wandern können sie alles rechnen mit
einfachen umformung so sehen wir nun an
beat das ganze aus der perspektive der
person in der raumflug kontrollstation
erscheint also außerhalb dieses
raumschiff fliegt das raumschiff
übersehen weg beobachtet die person
ebenfalls die reise des lichtpuls es von
der quelle zum ziel aus der pest aus
ihrer perspektive wird das ziel sich
während der zeit die der puls brauchte
um das ziel zu erreichen
relativ zu der stelle wo er sich befand
als der puls ausgestrahlt wurde nach
vorne bewegt haben das sieht dann
nämlich so aus also wir sie jetzt auch
von außerhalb des raumschiffs wir
betrachten sieht von außen wir sehen
jetzt hoppla das licht bewegt sich nicht
nach oben
das wäre jetzt 4
die vier meter sondern weil eben in der
zeit bis das licht nach oben gewandert
ist eben hier eine gewisse zeit
vergangen ist und dass branche sich
weiter gelegt hat wird sagen die
zurückgelegte strecke des lichts länger
sein nämlich 5 metern als vier metern
weil eben das ziel oben die zielscheibe
sich von dem ursprünglichen ort weg
bewegt hat weil es ja in einem bewegten
system sich vollzogen haben und jetzt
und das ist sozusagen jetzt die ganze
dass der ganze klub ist wenn sie das
jetzt verstehen ist eigentlich total
einfach
dann haben sie das grundprinzip der
relativitätstheorie eigentlich
verstanden sage jetzt mal behauptet
jetzt mal also abbildung 3 fliegt das
raumschiff über ihr der kontrollpersonen
vorbei bewegt sich das ziel für die
person in der raumflug kontrollstation
also an diesem anführungsstrichen festen
ort auf der erde der natürlich auch
bewegt ist aber natürlich jetzt
gleichförmig bewegt ist und deswegen
kann man es wieder verbindung sehen auf
der erde derzeit die der lichtpuls für
seine reise braucht vorwärts der puls
muss demnach eine diagonale strecke
durchlaufen als aus der perspektive des
raumschiffs bewegt sich der puls von
unten nach oben
aus der perspektive des äußeren
betrachters bewegt sich der puls in so
einer diagonalen von erlebt also mehr
weg zurück lichtpuls der gleichen zeit
in der der weg im raumschiff ein meter
kürzer war das ist also das ist jetzt
der clou und durch diese verschiebung
von vier meter auf fünf meter haben wir
jetzt diese diese zeit die nation da
haben wir jetzt hier eine eine praktisch
zeit veränderungen durch diesen anderen
weg der hier zurückgelegt wird können
wir schließen da sich die zeit im
raumschiff langsam verhält als aus aber
es nicht stimmt aus ihrer sicht der
kontroll person außerhalb ist der pfad
nicht senkrecht sollen geneigt also hier
diese schräge die länge dieses geneigten
tages wird eindeutig größer sein als die
länge des pfades aus der sicht der
astronauten nämlich fünf meter statt
vier metern
nehmen wir an dass das raumschiff sich
in der zeit
lichtpuls braucht um von der quelle zum
ziel zu wandern um drei meter vorwärts
bewegt unter verwendung des satzes von
tagoes demzufolge 3 im quadrat +4 im
quadrat gleich fünf im quadrat ist sehen
wir dass die strecke die der lichtpuls
durchläuft um zum ziel zu lang für die
personen der kontrollstation fünf meter
beträgt
also gehen wir zurück
wir haben satz stark 15 im quadrat also
dass praktisch c quadrat gleiche quadrat
fahrer gleich also vier im quadrat +3
quartal ist einfacher satz tage was wir
kommen gleich noch zum ausrechnen wie
groß ist nun die zeit die sie für den
bewegten lichtpuls berechnet sie ist
offen sich die zurückgelegte entfernung
5 meter als die längere strecke war es
jetzt ja eine diagonale ist geteilt
durch die fortpflanzungs geschwindigkeit
des lichts wir hatten gesehen dass diese
geschwindigkeit c ist dieselbe wie für
die astronauten
es gibt also keine schnellere
lichtgeschwindigkeit für die person in
der kontrollstation ist also die mit
ihrer uhr gemessene zeit gleich fünf
durchziehen und nicht mehr gleich vier
durchziehen das 10
das ist also unterschied außerhalb wird
praktisch praktisch eine andere zeit
ergeben
und jetzt rechnet das mal aus das ist
aber nicht die zeit die die astronauten
gemessen hat nach ihrer messung war die
zeit spricht gleich vier durch also im
raumschiff war die zeit also fünf nicht
15 sondern 416 ein bisschen kürzer
sozusagen
als bisschen kleiner seiten stimmen also
nicht darüber ein wie lange der
lichtpuls für seine reise gebraucht hat
weil eine unterschiedliche länge
zurückgelegt hat einmal fünf meter durch
die diagonale und einmal vier meter von
unten nach oben
für die person in der kontrollstation
ist die anzeige auf der us astronautin
zu niedrig deren uhr geht langsamer als
ihre eigenen
das ist also da haben sie jetzt
praktisch die die zeit die nation zeit
die nation heißt zeitverzögerung zeit
schrumpfen
wer also während auch in der
kontrollstation eine bestimmte zeit
vergangen ist ist für diese strecke für
das zurücklegen dieser strecke genau
genommen
für diesen ja für diese strecke ist es
in dem raumschiff ist die zeit langsamer
voran gegangen für denselben vorgang für
denselben vorgang für das fliegen von
der unteren quelle zur oberen
zielscheibe von selben vorgang für
dasselbe ereignis und theologisch
gesprochen ist einmal mehr zeit
verstrichen
aus der sicht der kontrollstation und
einmal weniger zeit verstrichen im
raumschiff
deswegen ist die uhr dort langsam
langsamer gelaufen im porsche und nicht
nur die uhr auch alle anderen ereignisse
im rausch es sind im selben maße
verlangsamt wäre des landes würde die
astronautin merken können dass ihre uhr
nachgeht vergleich etwa zu ihrer
herzfrequenz oder zu der zeit die einen
wasserkessel zum kochen braucht usw
und das würde ihr die folgerung
gestatten dass sie sich bewegt also dass
ihre geschwindigkeit den uhr mechanismus
irgendwie beeinflusst aber solches wird
von relativität ausgeschlossen
jede gleich für bewegung ist relativ das
leben aus der perspektive der
astronautin muss genauso vor sich gehen
wie für die person in der
kontrollstation daraus schließen wir
dass alles was im raum das geschieht die
uhr die funktionsweise elektronik die
alterungsprozesse der astronauten ihre
denkvorgänge alle im selben maße
verlangsamt sind betrachtet sie ihre
langsame mit ihrem langsam gehirn wird
nichts als fehlerhaft erscheinen aus
ihrer perspektive heraus erscheint alles
im rausch normalen und verändert sich im
selben takt das ist nicht nur die uhr
die im raumschiff langsame tickt sind
das gehirn schickt ja auch langsamer und
die alterungsprozesse ticken auch
langsamer als im raumschiff alt hat man
langsamer deswegen ist es auch das
hatten auch festgestellt wenn sie den
flug machen dem flugzeug mit dieser
geringen geschwindigkeit eines flugzeugs
ungefähr 1000 km h altern sie minimal
langsamer als sie erhalten würden wenn
sie
währenddessen auf der erde sind
natürlich bewegt sich die erde ja auch
noch in der zeit aber diese zusätzlich
geschwindigkeit ein flugzeug füttert so
dass sie etwas langsamer gealtert sind
genau richtig es geht immer relativ nah
auf der erde bewegen sich natürlich auch
schon gemessen die er hat ja auch eine
eigene und rim arbeitet das addiert sich
eben jetzt in diesem fall ist es auch
jetzt wollen wir das mal ausrechnen
nur für die person in der
kontrollstation ist im raumschiff alles
verlangsamt das ist das phänomen der
zeit die nation die astronautin hat ihre
zeit und die person in der grund weil
station hat ebenfalls ihre zeit
diese beiden zeiten zur nicht identisch
und das spricht jetzt genau gegen
newtons begriff der absoluten zeit
verrinnt eben nicht überall gleichmäßig
schnell sagt einstellen im raumschiff
bringt sie langsamer als auf die
kontrollstation
und jetzt sprechen wir das mal aus es
geht also nur mit satspeed ago raus
also machen wir das mal kurz hier wir
haben jetzt die größen hier
wir wollen jetzt mal eine formel bringen
wir haben hier ein recht rechtwinklige
dreieck und sie können jetzt sagen sie
haben da drei sehen die buchstaben a b c
also wir können sagen haben satz im
quadrat im quadrat gleich dem quadrat
macht es nicht ganz korrekt + b c
quadrat kag quadrat der c quadrat das
ist mit gespielten prognose die ergibt
sich durch die quadrate der seitenlangen
und jetzt will ich raus haben ich will
jetzt also praktisch c strich willich
ausrechnen c strich ist mein ziel
als ich das muss praktisch auf a- b-
gehen auf die seite aber dann habe ich
hier a b quadrat gleich zehn quadrat - b
c quadrat - 3
so geht es und jetzt muss ich halt
auflösen nach ich kann jetzt hier eben
einsätzen für abb setzt sich ein ct
strich quadrat
ich kann das auch so machen ich lebe das
quadratische mit 310 x te strich im
quadrat gleichsetzen ac 1 ac ist sie
quadrat theo quadrat nicht t strich noch
ein bisschen mehr - bc ist das ist tv
mal tv quadratmetern quadrat und jetzt
muss ich einfach hier
ich will ja t strich haben jetzt muss
ich das ganze eben durch die quadrate
teilen das heißt die strikt quadrat
gleich ich muss jetzt das ziel hier
herunter dividieren da kann ich gleich
haus nehmen gleich quadrat - praktisch
an
v
genau
x mal c quadrat durch c quadrat genau
richtig genau richtig das genau und
jetzt ich mache mal kurz ein bisschen
kürzer dass ich es mal sehen wie es dann
folgendermaßen aussieht also wir haben
das jetzt so weit bist hier geschafft
also das kommt dann letztendlich
dividieren das ganze durch c quadrat
genau wie klammern das aus und dann
haben wir hier gibt sich genau und rtl
in den nächsten schritten
dann gibt sich also 1 - v quadrat durch
c quadrat moment schon mal kurz richtig
genau genau
das klingt jetzt alles sehr kompliziert
also tt strich ist das jetzt haben wir
hier die wurzeln noch die wurzel noch
genau die strich ist dann die wurzel aus
13 c quadrat mal wenn wir jetzt hier
doch die die wurzel ziehen dann haben
wir das quadrat wecken das ist jetzt
alles sehr abstrakte zahmer t strich
ausreichend also die zeit die praktisch
im flugzeug verrinnt und jetzt wollen
wir die mal kurz noch interpretieren der
letzten minute nach die zeit vergeht
natürlich sehr schnell
sie schauen jetzt einfach mal kurz hier
rein also wenn jetzt die geschwindigkeit
des flugzeugs alle des bewegten systems
wenn die geschwindigkeit des flugzeugs
wenn die jetzt ungefähr so groß wie die
lichtgeschwindigkeit
da ergibt sich hier auf ca dann geht das
geht ein gegen cns lichtgeschwindigkeit
sei dann bekommen sie hier praktisch
c-quadrat durch c quadrat es gibt 1 sie
würden dann praktisch haben in der in
der wurzel 11 das ist null und die
wurzel von null ist 0 und 0 x tekken 0
das heißt die geschwindigkeit t strich
dass die geschwindigkeit im raumschiff
die wäre die zeit also die zeit im raum
steht ist er strich die wäre wenn sie
sich im raumschiff mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen würde wäre
die praktisch null
das ist das ist die folgerung dass der
ganzen sache also wenn sie sich mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen dann
vergeht praktisch keine zeit
dann ist die zeit so verlangsamt das
praktisch keine zeit mehr vergeht
das ist also die folge
und je mehr sie in richtung
lichtgeschwindigkeit gehen desto eben
mehr verlangsamt sich die zeit ja
desto kleiner wird je mehr je mehr v
gegen c geht desto desto kleiner wird
tee strich also sie können das praktisch
ganz gehen am nächste sitzung noch mal
ganz kurz darauf ein ist ein bisschen
knapp gewonnen als sie sehen sie können
mit einer ganz einfachen rechnung satz
des pythagoras wurzel und ausklappen und
so können sie dieses prinzip aufzeigen
dieses relativitätstheorie in bewegten
system die geschwindigkeit also
praktisch dass die zeit langsamer
vergeht in bewegten system und zwar
deswegen ich fast sagen weil die
lichtgeschwindigkeit eben immer dieselbe
ist man sich immer dieselbe ist und sich
nicht addiert gut wie kommt das nächste
mal ganz kurz darauf zurück dass es noch
mal das cern hier sehen sie diese
beschleunigung beschleunigungs röhre
das ist die röhre und willkommen
nächsten mal noch mal ganz kurz auf a3
steins text zu sprechen so sagt er aus
dem original
und auch noch mal ganz kurz nächste mal
auf diesen berühmten minkowski rahmen
der sieht so aus in zukunft nichts
lichtkegeln vergangenheit lichtkegel und
wir wollen denn auch noch mal ganz kurz
diskutieren dann bis zum wechsel sind